hey y'all welcome to another episode of
is this okay where we talk about things
and ask the question is this okay we're
talking about cheating and is it okay to
cheat uh Chris have you ever been
cheated on I've been the other and
before and it was very traumatizing but
I feel that because I've also been made
I've been in situations where I was the
other woman and like you just kind of
you don't want to feel like dirty it
makes you feel yeah that's society I'm a
consenting adult like I thought that we
were both going into something on the
same terms I'm like clearly we weren't
and you kept that from me you have to
choose between her me then it was never
meant to be there's another saying
you're only as sick as your secrets and
I think like you hang on to that [ __ ]
then it eats at you this might be like a
bad time to say that I have cheated
before I've been on all sides of the
situation so I've cheated I've been
cheated on and I've been the other man
so I feel like confessions yeah and I'm
not even like I feel like cheating
happens that might be like it happens it
happens to you it happens with you it's
like it's inevitable as a part of like
dating and complicated [ __ ]
human beings want to [ __ ] right and I
just think like can I be and we get into
these like contractually binding
relationships without realizing that
like four years down the road you want
to flip someone else there's the thing
I'm gonna add to that I think a lot of
times we get with people and we're not
totally honest about what we want
absolutely actually sexy yeah but don't
you think it's cuz we don't even know
that it's okay to want those things yes
and what that gets into me with what I
do as a coach as a dating coach I help
empower singles and so many singles
especially a mainstream America have
never been told it's okay to have like
to want things that are kind of kinky or
all these kind of things so then they go
behind their partner's back especially
like long-term relationships or
marriages because they don't want to
tell their partner
maybe told their partner in pieces and
their partners like you and judging them
so everyone's gonna go cheap like
there's emotional cheating there's
flirtation is uncomfortable for some
people so it's this possessiveness and
this jealousy it'd be honest with me do
you want to be in an open relationship
we could talk about that we can work
that out which means that you're having
sex with other people I don't care
carry on another relationship that's my
line I don't want to have a so whole
other separate relationship but that's
for me there's some people who want to
be poly and have like just three four or
five relationships and they can manage
that that [ __ ] seems like a Ponzi scheme
to me and it's even a lot of work let's
think there's no one style of
relationship so for you your boundary or
your hardline heart no was I can't be in
relationship with someone who's having
other relationships you're so right for
someone else that could be fine some
people might be like you can flirt with
other people some people might be like
you can't flirt with anyone not even
flirty yeah you can't female or male
friends I mean just it's about having
the greenback's wings you that's crazy
to me that seems a beauty that's like a
line appears we can't judge because for
if two people agree upon a certain
amount of traits like a contract right
you agreement on the same things if
you're those two people or power many
people are involved agree then who are
we to judge if that works for them right
what is a problem we're cheating comes
in is when people are in agreement more
people are hiding things
I wonder if anyway if it's like a
hardline cheating you're done for me is
it's not a hard-line there needs to be
more of a conversation and then if in
that conversation we're on the same page
we've listened there's respect there
then I can move forward with that person
if it was judgment or if I felt like
that person were just like nope nope
sorry I can't deal with anything you're
talking about the nuts when I probably
think I've been in a relation
we're like my first live cheated on me
multiple times and it got to the point
where I know before you told no I and I
ended up finding out because I snooped i
snooped and I like had known previously
that he had done it before and it wasn't
like it wasn't sexually cheating but it
was emotionally and so that still took a
toll on me and I think he's worse I
think emotional
I think emotional is worse I haven't
been cheated on but I have been made to
the other woman so for me I want to say
cheating might be a deal-breaker for me
only because I'm so open and direct and
I'm like all about conversation all
about hearing your side of things trying
to work through things so to find out
that you would then go do that what if
your person [ __ ] somebody meant
nothing they were drunk and then they
came to you like hat in hand and we're
like I cheated I [ __ ] up real no real
yeah if I can be really honest on but
honestly I would rather just not know
like if it was a if it was a one-time
thing about nothing to you it was an
accident I'd rather not know
but then it's what you said like once
the trust is gone like I'm gonna be you
get crazy like where are you who you
texting white top on her whatever I
can't do that I just rather not know the
one relationship I haven't cheated on
has been this five year relationship I'm
in which is my wife and I feel like the
reasons I've cheated before
to give you answer to of like what was
it they kind of like made me cheat I
felt like I wasn't being emotionally
fulfilled in some way and I felt like
there was something missing that people
didn't like me for who I was I was like
[ __ ] it I'll go get my needs met by
someone who still thinks I'm shiny and
new I think we get caught up in that
especially in American society
like things have to be forever and if it
wasn't reverence a failure and then all
these things and it's like no maybe they
just ran its course people are like oh
you know I've been with this person for
five years so I guess I owe them
marriage like I mean I thought decade
relationship that I was in I was like
I'm gonna get married and then I thought
I didn't want to get married period but
then when I met my wife I was like oh I
want to spend the rest of my life with
this person and I know because she loves
me unconditionally and I don't think I
had ever gotten
unconditional love before like from my
parents or otherwise and I also give
that kind of love to her I realize like
oh this is what you could work on
forever because it's you accept each
other perfectly can grow and change with
each other you know I'm saying you get
this whole bunch of like rocky shitty
relationships up until the the one that
wasn't you know what I mean the thing
I'd like to say is respect know what
your boundaries are to know what's
cheating for you and if you feel like
someone has overstepped your boundaries
be as honest with you can with yourself
and with that person going forward and
again yeah like all of you excited I
mean there's gray areas it's not black
and white so don't feel pressure to just
make a decision based on society your
friends or family it's your relationship
and it's your decision and act with act
act with respect to yourself and do
what's going to like you up and make you
happy because that's really the bottom
line of all of this is that we should
bring people in our lives and live in
relationships that make us happy
Wow